introducing the first forum of the fall
term not only because we have such a
surfeit of glory on our panel uh uh but
but also because it gives me an
opportunity to introduce seth manukin
who is the uh who has agreed to take on
the job of
co-director of the mit communications
forum and i'm looking forward to many
more sessions in with in which seth
moderates and helps uh orchestrate the
events of the forum uh i won't uh take
the time to talk about seth's own
credentials except to say uh he seems a
godsend to me and i feel i feel very
fortunate to have him as a collaborator
in continuing to create interesting
forums
the uh the website uh the forum website
which you can now see on the screen
lists are our other events for the
semester uh i hope they're there and i
hope i'll see you at those events as
well it remains for me only to say that
those of you in the audience who have
not uh signed up for the mit
communications forum mailing list please
do so we never give the list to anyone
we never send advertisements out you
never get any push
ads on your word uh
urgings to download something you don't
want we only send out information about
our events
and you receive a very small number of
emails but you are kept in touch with
the forum's activities so please do sign
up if you can
seth
thank you very much david and uh thank
you all from for coming out i know that
um there is a plethora of riches at mit
this afternoon
but
we hope that this will be time well
spent i'm going to very briefly
introduce
the four people who are on the panel uh
as i've told some of you out there i
know there are a lot of phoenix alums
out in the audience um
the selection of the panel was somewhat
arbitrary only in that
there are really an incredible number of
incredible phoenix alumni who are living
in the area who he could have
included
i took advantage of this as a chance to
collect some people that i wanted to
hear from and talk to
but
a good portion of this next hour and 45
minutes will be spent uh on audience
questions and discussions and comments
uh and i hope that you all take
advantage of that
um so uh the going from stage left to
right uh the is that right yes um the
first uh um the first person uh seated
is lloyd schwartz who
is the frederick s troy professor of
english at umass boston uh he is a long
time poet and in addition to his three
and a half works of poetry uh he is a
particular expert on elizabeth bishop
and has edited or co-edited
several collections of her work
he started working at the boston phoenix
in 1977
and worked there essentially straight
through to this spring
when the phoenix went out of business
as the classical music critic and then
classical music editor
he also is the winner of the pulitzer
prize for criticism uh that he won in
1994 as a member of the phoenix staff
after which he got a call from the new
york times asking them to immediately
send his work to them and then never
heard back
uh next is charlie pierce um who
if you don't know already when he speaks
you will probably recognize his voice um
from his uh well not just because he has
a loud projected voice that you can hear
around boston but from his frequent um
appearances on npr's wait wait don't
tell me and only a game
he's the author of four books including
the 2009 bestseller idiot america
he was a boston globe sunday magazine
staff writer for nine years ending in
2011.
he has been a writer at large at esquire
since 1997 and now writes esquire's
politics blog
and also writes for as a staff writer at
grantland
is it technically grantland.com or just
grantland grantland.com okay
which is a fantastic site
next along the line we have anita
diamond who began as
no oh no i'm sorry
shortly next in my line not next in the
actual line um how dare you
not sit the way i typed you into my
iphone
next we have carly carioli who i
actually met um
20 something years ago 20 years ago
when he i think was an intern at the
phoenix and
i felt like i had broken into their
offices and was writing a couple of arts
reviews some music reviews um the music
critics at the phoenix were terrifying i
don't think that ever ended and the
biggest talking down i ever received was
uh in a review of a of a roger daltrey
pete townsend concert i misidentified
one of the members of the back in band
um
as the wrong relationship to pete
townsend and his family um and it was as
if i had spelled the president's name
wrong uh carly um has been at the
phoenix straight through since he
started as an intern uh did the listings
um was a listings editor was a calendar
editor
then went on to be an editor and
eventually the editor
of the phoenix
first on the website and then of the
newspaper and finally of the magazine
he was the final editor of the phoenix
and is now at boston magazine
and uh i will probably not embarrass him
by quoting some of the things he said
about boston magazine over the years
and the pages of the phoenix
globe did the same thing to me it was
horrible
um uh yeah carly was briefly worked at
the globe before he went to awesome
magazine and uh he also had some not
great things to say about them over the
years um next finally is anita uh and um
anita began uh as an assistant to the
editor is that right at the phoenix in
1978 um and stayed there until 1983
which actually i skipped this over with
charlie but is the exact same time frame
uh that charlie was at the phoenix
um totally coincidental they assure me
uh
she um started out writing profiles and
eventually a first-person column um at
the phoenix in addition to
writing a lot about um feminist issues
about religion
about personal issues uh
um and since she's left the phoenix has
become
a best-selling author several times over
most notably of 1997's the red tent
her most recent book is 2009's day after
night
and somehow in between all that she
found time to be a staff writer at the
boston globe magazine for 10 years
back when the boston globe magazine was
still
running long stories um so that's the
four of them um uh as i said i'm gonna
try and direct the conversation for the
first 45 minutes to an hour uh i'm going
to interpret my job as mainly being one
to to get out of the way
so
i want to start carly with you um just
because you were there at the end uh and
i know you've said that you were
surprised
on the day that it happened because i
think it the actual announcement came
without a huge amount of warning um but
was that something that you were
surprised about in in a larger sense
when it happened
uh oh wait don't talk yet uh one last
thing if you're live vlogging um the
hashtag uh is phoenix mit p h e o n i x
mit
ph yeah however you spell phoenix then
followed by mit
right
here right there
okay so carly uh the question was was i
surprised um
i think uh
i think a lot of us understood that the
paper um especially once we switched
from a newspaper to a magazine um
what that we were doing um sort of an
experiment that
just back up for one second and so the
the phoenix had been a newspaper uh
primarily a broadsheet for uh most of
its existence since it started um in the
late 60s or early 70s depending on when
you date its inception
and then what what changes happened in
its format over the last couple years um
uh so i mean it went from the broadsheet
obviously to sort of the tabloidy thing
this is these are actually the portland
and providence phoenixes which are still
around um and we have a we had it
delivered by an actual mintage um to our
to this you just came out today this
fall preview um so uh
i i'm i'm blanking on the date i think
it was i guess the early part of it was
like the september of
2012 maybe somewhere in there where we
um
we were um given the ultimatum
to over the course of six weeks turn
this 46 year old newspaper into a glossy
magazine um
and that was because um
the finances were not great the finances
of newspapers in general hadn't been
great
we'd survived a lot of
downturns in the industry
but the phoenix was
by all accounts losing um still losing a
pretty a pretty big amount of money and
um
so as kind of a last-ditch attempt to uh
to revive
the brand we sort of um came up this
this crazy notion to combined um the
phoenix and um in our glossy lifestyle
magazine stuff magazine into a single
publication that would be weekly um and
try and keep as much of
the phoenix's identity as we could and
we relaunched that after sort of under
um
insane conditions where our offices were
also being renovated and they're
jackhammers and we were putting together
this thing that we'd never done before
so the magazine came out
i loved it i thought it was great um i
think we were all pretty proud of it
it was all done and the entire thing was
done it was designed in-house it was you
know um
sort of built from scratch
and um and then um and things seemed to
be going well especially at the
beginning um it was fat um people seemed
to like it um
and then but we but i guess my point was
that at that point we understood that um
that that was an experiment that and
that we had probably
you know a limited amount of time to try
and make that work and and stephen
mindich the publisher of the phoenix
sort of made that um
clear to um to many of us who had sort
of been there for a long time
so um
you know it the reason that it wasn't a
total shock um we were still surprised
at the timing we thought we had more
time
but
the magazine itself
was getting sort of thinner and thinner
i mean the advertising pages just
weren't there so um in that sense it it
um
you know it began to take on a kind of
an inevitability but um
but even at the end it was it was still
kind of a shock even now it's still kind
of a shock
um and and charlie uh and anita um you
can both jump in on this but
when we were talking just before the
forum started we were talking about some
of the ways in which um
the phoenix covered the news and the
types of things that the phoenix covered
that was distinct from what was
happening at the globe or anyplace else
uh locally can you talk a little bit
about that no you start yeah yeah
come on charlie
they came to hear you come here
hi
what i did there for five years which
was essentially right for the news
section although i did do a number of
things for lifestyle and for the
supplements
because i was writing for my rent so and
more words i wrote the easier was to pay
the rent
but
we were sort of i thought we were sort
of the
first generation produced
by the long-form narrative non-fiction
that came out in new york in the 1970s
the the stuff that tom wolf put in
anthology called the new journalism
although it wasn't really new and are
you talking about new york magazine or
just
magazine harper's on conference under
william morris
esquire esquire under the latter days of
fuse and you know and so forth
and i think that
we were sort of the
next generation of that we
we covered we covered almost everything
the globe covered but we did it at
length and we did it with voice and we
did it with attitude a terrible word but
that's what it was
uh and we i at least when i got there in
1978 it had already carved out a niche
within the media
biosphere in boston for that kind of
thing i can't speak to the arts coverage
although i know we were you know the
arts coverage was brilliant and
we can talk to that
but from our side of it
i would go out and write long
impressionistic pieces from the campaign
trail or from or about
you know the guy i did a piece a long
piece about the last uh porno house in
chelsea where i had to go
with a seven-year-old judge and a whole
bunch of jurors who i don't think have
ever recovered to go watch a movie so
they could so they could witness the
evidence do you remember the movie i do
not i do not remember the movie uh uh
the judge's name was rudolph stanziani i
remember that
but i do not remember the movie but it
was back in the days where they had
plots and so forth but
in any way that's what i that's what i
thought we were that's what i watch what
i came there to do
uh and i think you know for the balance
of the time i was there that's what we
did
and uh you know subsequently i think a
lot of that got absorbed into dailies
but at the time we were the ones who i
mean the new york the washington post
style section was doing it but hardly
anybody else was doing it around the
country in dallas
i um i started out answering the phone
and filing photographs which is pretty
much how women got into the newsroom
anyway um i don't know how the arts
section worked and this was so just to
remind everyone so in the late 70s um
for you felt still to get into the
newsroom and by that point you had been
a journalist for a couple i was a
freelancer and i had been a freelancer
and i'd written for
um
equal times which was a
women's bi-weekly that had lived for
several years and i very good wrote
everything in there under many names
and i learned a lot um and no i thought
renee loft had the job of assistant to
the editor rene loth um who many of you
may know was a statehouse brilliant
state house reporter um she was at that
desk briefly and she went right to the
state house and um became the editor the
editorial page editor of the globe most
recently
and so that i got the job after that and
um
i remember we had a file called phone
calls from the dead that were you know
we had really strange phone calls and um
and it was it was my wayne and i then i
wrote over the tr handed things in over
the transom
to bob sales who was the first editor
who um really taught me how to write in
a lot of ways um and richard gaines and
then andy zellman who was the
lifestyle editor who had started by
answering the phones at the front desk
um
took me out to lunch and said that i had
more opinions than anyone she'd ever met
and she and she offered me a column uh
which
was amazing and i got to write whatever
i wanted uh with the and the freedom of
that was remarkable and
i think um
i think what i was doing and what a lot
of us were doing at that time was
reinventing the women's pages um that
the the lifestyle section had its own uh
footprint uh and when you say women's
pages it's not that there were literally
women's pages in the phoenix no it was
it was it was just the soft stuff
which the women's movement had
identified as core
important stuff that needed to be
covered and that included
everything from women's health to
fashion to um to politics and the way
women were discussed in the media um and
with humor and with attitude and also
with integrity in terms of reporting so
i felt one of the things i i felt that
the phoenix always did with whatever
attitude was that we had to do the work
we had to do the reporting and that the
facts had to be there and so that um
whenever people sort of you know raised
an eyebrow about the phoenix it was like
it's really it's good journalism it's
solid it was really all of it was solid
and the lifestyle section was solid and
had news in it as well
so i just pulled up your your porn again
um piece it actually is not from 2006.
uh it's from 1982 i think is that right
does that sound right sounds right which
was um uh a piece you wrote um a great
piece about uh a debate between andrea
dworkin um and alan dershowitz oh god um
which which which i i should point out
when the phoenix um ran it in their
flashback section in 2006 alan
dershowitz wrote in again
14 years later to to
correct the record to correct what keith
i've been on panels with him since then
and he's absolutely the same
person um
uh but but so i i i i just want to do
that that's the kind of thing that
happened all the time
you would you would people would get
something in their teeth and they would
not let it go yeah yeah and that's what
the phone calls from the dead was about
yeah
but so you know we're talking about how
um the phoenix was and and all weeklies
i think uh in general certainly the
voice during the late 70s early 80s was
doing
long-form reportage
but i also want to just get at some of
the distinctions between the actual
subject matter so was this something
that you would see covered or written
about in this way in the globe or in any
other
i don't think so um and i think this
would just this was a huge event i mean
there were there were a lot of people
there was concerns about violence there
was there was a lot right there and i
don't remember if there was global
coverage but i
i know that we did much many more inches
uh and
and i was given uh a lot of space and
time as much as i needed and support to
do this and i actually think part of
what we did um in the lifestyle section
was i take stories that that the women's
movement and feminism had identified and
um
and actually elevate them to some extent
by making them well reported well
written and not screeds
and uh and also and that gave it more
legitimacy i think i think the content
guy had more legitimacy i think it's
written that way i think that's an
important point
we almost wrote
there were almost no
straight opinion pieces at the phoenix
when i was there what people looking at
oh pornography kind of
we have a theme going i got a kind of
thing going on with my neck
no uh
we the the the stories and the reporting
was full of was full of of analysis and
interpretation and opinion
but there were almost there were very
few
as anita said screeds i mean they were i
mean there were there was an occasion
there were there were columns that were
clearly designated as columns phoenix
editorials didn't come in until until
almost the time i was leaving
uh but
the distinction between
allowing a guy to go i mean you know the
thing that you know and i don't want to
go off on political reporting but
the
on the on the one hand on the other hand
thing didn't exist yeah at the phoenix
it just didn't happen
the you know faux balance didn't happen
we were i mean our politics were left
there was no question about that
but at the same time i think i did a lot
of work with republicans just at the
beginning of the reagan administration
just as the what was then and i also did
a piece on a thing called washington for
jesus which was the first
major rally of what became the religious
right
and
they were as we were willing to be fair
we weren't gonna i mean i mean we were
never gonna agree with these folks but
they would come i would get my phone
calls returned from republicans and from
the people of washington for jesus
because they knew that basically i was
willing to listen to them for a half an
hour and usually and and use whatever i
could as part of my reporting
but there were very very few
straight out
yelling your face kind of screeds and
i i i pulled up allen's uh letter um in
2006 and the reason was just because he
quotes the globe article that covered
this and what's interesting is um
i think anita your piece was
uh
much less did not try and hide opinion
as fact it presented a much more
complete picture of the facts and um you
could draw your interpretations from
that uh and the globe um did almost the
exact opposite and it described it as
what these men and women saw and some of
them created was an ugly collision
between 40 enraged radical feminists and
dershowitz who defended free speech and
became a symbol for the entire legal
system which i think you would be
hard-pressed to draw that conclusion
from alvin was an
alan was horrible and people reacted so
um but but let me just one last thing
that i wrote an opinion calling was in
my name but i had to report i had to
support my opinions with reporting um
and i was told to go back and get get a
quote from somebody that i couldn't just
say that that i had to support it with
either you know a citation from
somewhere and i that that was i don't
see that anywhere very much anymore
yeah we were we were gifted with
tremendous tremendous editors and i
don't
mean strictly the editors of the
newspaper although certainly bob sales
anita and i hope bob sales that we can
never repay but i'm talking about things
like people like david moran who's here
uh tom frail the late john ferguson oh
god the late cliff garbodan i'm going to
go down the little reckless hit reckless
they worked you and i have been through
a bunch of different magazines since
then nobody and nobody worked me harder
than those guys did i mean what i'll
tell you
esquire is is a breeze compared to
submitting a piece to david or john or
tommy was
because it was i mean
you had to have done your due diligence
and it was a great training ground it
was a great training ground for
accepting
the fundamental necessity of editors
which writers don't often do very well
uh but uh
i think that was very important and i
think i didn't realize that about the
column because i never had a column but
yeah i mean it was it was it was a it
was a gauntlet and you had and you had
to run it and it was terrific
lloyd i i wanna um jump over to what i
think uh
a lot of people saw as one of the
defining features of the phoenix um
throughout all of its incarnations and
that's the the arts coverage um uh it
was where growing up in boston i learned
almost everything i knew about music
and i think one thing that really
distinguished the phoenix
from the globe and from the way
newspapers generally were covering the
arts is
it wasn't enough that you were
interested in something you ought to
really have a deep
well of knowledge to
be deemed appropriate to to criticize it
is that
well this was true of the art section
and and
and it
it began by being true
because there was so much space
available
i mean i i my
favorite
figure so you couldn't go on for 3000
words if you didn't know what you were
talking right and i'm thinking of the
person who did go who did go on for
three thousand words with stephen schiff
who was the phoenix movie critic movie
editor
and who was sort of notorious for going
on talking about a new film or an old
film that would take up three entire
phoenix pages and in the days when the
phoenix was actually bigger
than it then it became
a ten-point type also probably
that that i don't remember i could still
read it
in those days
um
but we really were
no one was given
a
space
limit
and it was a kind it was an amazing kind
of freedom to have
and i don't think anyone
took advantage of that in
the worst way
that is
people who
but that people who wrote
about the arts in boston and this man
rock music because
we had i think short of
maybe
or along with rolling stone
we had the best rock
critics
in the country
and
movies
seriously who were some of those critics
who then because
i was thinking about trying to
list all the phoenix critics that had
gone on to national prominence and we
just could have spent the entire hour
doing that but during that period who
were some of those critics well kit
rackless uh who
then became an editor of the la times
magazine and la weekly and
there's a very very long list and this
is like the thing that terrifies miles
here um yeah i mean so i mean like i
mean mark moses uh but that entire
rolling stone staff i think at that time
i mean the original rolling stone crew
was also running for phoenix you have
like dave marsh back there and and you
know chris gow was in there occasionally
and um i mean we found lester banks
pieces back in the archives i mean just
this
anybody who was anybody
just one just one
i saw it
well it's funny too because the same p
he ran the same we figured out he ran
the same piece like a year later
somewhere else and somebody else had
like you know obviously not edited him
so with the phoenix version was a much
better piece it goes to charlie's point
um
but i mean reading through those
archives is just astonishing i mean kit
rackless um who's now the editor of the
american prospect i met him at a
conference he's got white hair he looks
very distinguished he um was in atlanta
when the sex pistols landed for their
first u.s show and and there's you know
there's a phoenix review of the first
sex muscle show in america which always
astonished me um
but that that legacy is really really
deep and and not only that it it um you
know i can say certainly when i got
there in 1993 sort of echoing um
charlie's stories about becoming a
writer there um there was no greater
place on earth to like learn your craft
um i i showed up to phoenix um a kid
from philadelphia with hair down to his
ass who knew nothing about anything
except that is actually true heavy metal
and um a little bit about punk rock um
and the editors there were john guerilla
who's here uh ted rustowski who um maybe
roadie for his band that's how he got
the gig
and um and matt asher who seemed to know
everybody in town and played in bands
with people and um and that sort of
apprenticeship
uh for four years of just sort of you
know walking into a room where people
would tell you what to read and what to
listen to what magazines and what
writers and
that was you know that was constant that
was something that you know was that was
your sort of um your day-to-day thing
was just talking about music and arguing
about music and and and film and
current
rock music popular music uh was
certainly the center
and and always got the most attention
uh
at the in the phoenix art section
what is fascinating and what i am
you know
i will always be grateful for
is that there was always room
there was always the desire to
also include you know the the high
culture issues
there were so there were you know
brilliant rock cr uh brilliant art
critics david binetti who's also
here uh
uh
today uh
carolyn clay
uh writing about theater
uh
some you know people with
authoritative
voices
and the fact that
the phoenix was actually interested in
having
reviews of classical music and having
serious coverage of classical music
richard buell
before my time
uh whom i essentially replaced
uh
you know and that that even
when the phoenix was shrinking in those
last days and and probably the number of
people who actually
read classical music reviews was also
shrinking
that that steve mindich and the editors
actually
continued to want
that
aspect that
for me
crucial aspect of
boston culture
in the paper
was a a real testament to the the kind
of seriousness of
what it meant to be
interested in the arts and living in
boston and well so
i think one of the things that that does
and did distinguish the phoenix was this
um mix of of almost equal emphasis on
high-low um in terms of the arts and
engaging with them with a similar depth
of meaning
so
here i came to the phoenix after having
written for the herald for three years
speaking of high art speaking of high
art where
where i had
no space
and had to turn in
reviews
without thinking about them because they
were due the night of the concert nobody
not even the herald does that anymore or
the or the certainly not the globe
and
and then being butchered by especially
by the weekend editors i mean really
changing things and making mistakes and
a
continual embarrassment although it was
a great
that was my apprenticeship and then
coming to the phoenix
where i'm actually asked to write essays
about music
and getting the most serious
uh
responses from the editors i mean david
moran was certainly
here today with someone who actually
knew and was interested in classical
music the person who was editing me most
at the time was kit reckless who was a
rock critic and who really didn't know
much about classical music but who
really wanted to make sure that he could
understand what i was talking about and
that i was really backing up
everything that i had to say i had a lot
of opinions
and
i really had to support those opinions
those opinions the opinions
of the people writing about arts
weren't necessarily the most popular
opinions
for me
it was
my
profoundly and increasingly serious
reservations about seiji ozawa
being being the music director of the
boston symphony orchestra the most
important classical music institution in
you know in in certainly in this area
outside of new york in the east
and
even the globe i mean you know there
were very good critics writing for the
globe
but there was a kind of pressure
coming from
the
higher-ups at the globe
that you really had to be very careful
about what you said about the major
institutions
and this was not the case at the phoenix
and
i i i i think i was um
that it was important
to say that the emperor had no clothes
so i want to switch gears a little bit
and talk about what we think or what you
all think
is going to be missing from the boston
intellectual and journalistic scene
now that the phoenix is gone and i'll
preface that by saying that one of the
things that it seemed to me um as an
outsider that occurred over the last
decade or so was
you had the globe
um
either appropriating or exploring some
of the areas that the phoenix did
probably best represented by uh the
ideas section um which uh i don't know
if they hired peter canelos gareth and
steve hoiser all at the same time
but essentially just
took
a bunch of phoenix editors and and had
them make uh their own section um i know
stephen would be here tonight but he's
closing that section at the moment
and so in addition to that you had
a lot of what was being covered by
weeklies in the arts um moving over to
the internet so
despite the fact that we all will miss
the phoenix and and and it was integral
um in our lives
what are we actually going to be missing
in boston now that it's gone
you're missing
i mean just to start
really terrific writers
getting really seriously edited by
brilliant
editors
and there was there's just nothing else
like that i and it's certainly not on
the internet
and um i don't i don't see it i don't
see it anyplace else
carly
uh not in the times excuse me yeah i
mean i i i felt i i the
the trend you're describing is that of
the globe sort of trying to veer into
pop culture coverage and the and the web
those those things definitely happened
um
i mean not just the globe but you know
the time sure he's done that much more
successfully one of the things that i
you know that i used to say is that
the sort of the alt media crowd is that
you know the alternative media one the
idea was that there was this once this
hegemony of the of the mainstream media
and that the alternative
media was encroaching and sort of
breaking up that that pseudo monopoly um
it did that and the internet when it
sort of began to develop its own voice
took many elements of the of the
alternative weekly style um i think
that's i think that's true but um to
lloyd's point um there was a ton of
stuff that i mean there's a there were
many of us have gone off and and gone
different places but there are also
there were voices that i cared deeply
about even um in the very last phoenix
um two of them are here um that uh that
you won't see anywhere on boston you
won't see liz pelley writing about
underground music and
you know and and underground activism
you won't see matty myers writing about
feminist video game critics like
nobody's doing that in boston um and
they're both doing
astounding work um in other places but
not but not for the globe and not for
not for boston magazine and not for
any of the places that we represent
although i i assume that those places
are
available online so
functionally are they doing it for a
boston audience well i mean sure i mean
liz pele started a you know advertising
free um you know all weekly inspired
online thing called um the media
which is amazing and still is amazing um
and and and maddie stuff is obviously
available i mean um online but um you
know she's also writing a book so i mean
you know it depends on exactly what you
think
you know what what the if you want that
at length um and is that sustainable
you're talking about two people who were
getting paychecks from the phoenix and
are not getting paychecks now and you
know for people to sort of provide a
space for writers like that to to hone
their craft and learn how to be writers
that i mean there's an entire generation
of kids who just aren't going to get to
do that um and with all respect to the
dig which is a great paper um it's not
particularly sustainable at this point i
mean they're not paying people um the
same way that that we were and they
don't have the kind of scope that can
they can sort of pick up the slack i
hope they are able to grow into
something that can do that that would be
great
um
but uh but i think there's a huge hole
and anita i know you said that you had
not been a reader of the phoenix
recently do you think that's because you
you aged out or because you were getting
what you had been looking to the phoenix
for elsewhere
um yes and no i think i did age out but
i didn't see the phoenix anymore and we
were talking about that when it stopped
being sold
i stopped seeing it and that is that
being sold i think we figured roughly in
in the mid 90s is that right mid or late
90s it went from was it a buck 50 at
that point
yes sound right so it went from being a
buck 52 following the model that
virtually by that point every other
weekly had taken on including the voice
which was free distribution right and
that meant and that sort of felt like
well you're too old for this because
this is on college campuses for the most
part that's what it felt like anyway
even though i knew that there were and
every now and then i would pick it up
and read lloyd or carolyn clay who i
really who's
i think was he still is the best theater
critic in town um
but you know but i didn't see it again
for another six months or eight months
and so i felt you know that the hands
were somewhat washed and
and there are other places and i do
think the alternative media won in terms
of adding more voices to the mainstream
press um and to broadening what what's
covered in the mainstream press and of
course then the internet came and came
along and picked up everything um i'm
sorry about the i'm sorry to not have
known about the um
the video game
reviews because i've started reading
them in the times and i'm realizing
there's this whole universe that i need
to
learn more about
why do you need to learn more about it
because it's there because it's there
just because i the end because i'm
interested in what women are doing with
it and i and i was trying to follow that
a little bit but that's not happening in
locally anywhere else that i'm aware of
so i'm gonna have to figure out the
website but um but it's it is out there
what's missing is of course an address
for all of this stuff um an address to
find lloyd's what lloyd's writing and
what and what other really talented
people are writing which
is going to be somewhere on the internet
and charlie and i were talking about
this the internet is a baby we have no
idea what's going to happen with it and
how it's going to coalesce and how
branding is going to work and um how and
how we're going to start finding things
in the future and it's um it scares it
sort of scares the crap out of
paper people but um
we it's we won't know for quite for
quite some time how it's going to shake
out and how how we will find addresses
and how people who
um
need long form and deserve long form can
um can find their audiences out there
what's frustrating is that there's so
much and you don't know how to get it
and um
so it'll change yeah but i want to go
back to something carly mentioned right
at the end uh which it's an odd place
for me to be now because i am almost
entirely on all my work is entirely done
on the web now pretty much i do an
occasional piece for the dead tree
version of esquire
but
i work in a world of
very young people i do not i have not
since i left the globe magazine and
moved onto the internet i haven't had an
editor who's 30 years old yet
i mean i have
socks that are older than every editor
i'm wearing some now uh
but too much i do think that there's
something to be said
for
the wood shedding you have to do early
in your career as you'd especially as as
a writer as you develop yourself
and to get
you know a piece chucked that back at
you a couple times by david moran or or
john ferguson or somebody
uh and and and to develop your craft as
a writer
and i see that
sort of lacking
in web-based journalism i'm sure it'll
develop
uh as as as
the this as they need to said babies
grows up
but
i know that i would not be
whatever i am without having gone
through this process
and i think that was for me that was the
most valuable part about being at the
phoenix was was i walked out of the
phoenix in 1983
knowing everything i needed to know
about making a career and what i did uh
everything else was refinement
and i think that's what if you're asking
what what what the hole is that's the
whole
so it's finishing school exactly
well
that may be the first time the phoenix
has ever been described as finishing
school
graduate school people usually call it
graduate school
a little bit of history quickly sure
yes
you can grab the mic and we will in
about
eight minutes i don't want to start
going on on anything i'm i'm david
murray and the 10 years before these
distinguished people were there there
was an entire history of the paper
not just the rock critics
but the entire the way that we were
blessed to have sensationally talented
people come in like lloyd charlie and
anita all had predecessors 10 years of
predecessors
i'm certain
no but and i'm just saying
in fact anita and i came in at a moment
of great transition right how are you
calling my only point was when we're
talking about names or trying to reach
like robert kris gower names that
weren't really part of the phoenix but i
was hired by bill miller who was still
alive he was a globe news guy i'm the
one who hired frail and ferguson
um and it is bill miller and ken emerson
before me in the arts and all of these
and ben gerson before ken emerson and we
also the only other historical footnote
is we had dozens of women none of whom
started by answering the phone there was
no there's somebody's blogging and
saying that nida had to anita didn't
have to answer the phone people came in
wanting to answer the phone i wanted to
answer the phone it was my way no we
were i mean to get someone insanely
overeducated like anita who wanted to
join the paper that's fine but there are
15 anitas before anita
and there were feminists columnist karen
lindsey kerry grueson was an early
editor before my time so from 66 to 76
we're not going to work so i'm just from
66 to 77 let us say oh yeah we an entire
momentum
into which i mean you can step in the
same river twice
one of one of the challenges of putting
this together was figuring out how
you encompass almost a half century's
worth of history um uh with a tiny
handful of people in over a small amount
of time and and i was about to say well
david was talking in 78 79 when i got
there and anita got there the staff was
undergoing a great transition a lot of
the people today was talking about were
leaving diane dominoski left diane
dominoski howard you suck stu cohen
richard gaines became the editor
having done magnificent work as a state
house reporter uh so there was a lot of
room for there were there were huge
shoes for us to to step into and we
jumped into them with both feet to
really torture the metaphor
but
there was an enormous there was enormous
transition right between 1978 i never
met bill miller i was sorry you know he
preceded bob sales and uh you know there
were a few constants dave o'brien george
kimball
who we have not mentioned until this
point and that's too bad
uh you know and and i think tom sheehan
was already there
we i mean if i
if we if we named checked um we could we
would literally be here until 10 o'clock
uh um everyone at the phoenix and it's
not it's not not to
give everyone props um but i'm just i
just pointing out that there was this
this very kind of
great energy and turnover in this thing
i mean it was it was a it was as as
we've all shown it was a great place to
work your way up to the to what you
wanted to be but that also came along
with this we used to have these massive
turnovers i mean
it was healthy it wasn't it wasn't you
know by the by the 70s certainly i mean
the the the voice is um uh you know
rightfully cited as um sort of the first
big metro all weekly um i think a lot of
people don't realize that the phoenix
was really the second big um metro all
weekly and a lot of the innovations that
came to the form uh came out of boston
and out of the phoenix um uh and the
sort of new york oxygen sometimes i
think uh um overlooks that so i i do
want to make sure that we touch on one
last thing before we open it up and
that's um uh this sense of um
the attitude of the phoenix um orovalt
weeklies in general
uh shifting to the mainstream so the
notion that the alt weekly's won
and what that really means and what was
lost in that transition and i'll explain
a little bit what i'm talking about uh
dan kennedy who is here also um and uh
and right here uh and was worked at the
phoenix for a long time and is now a
media critic um wrote something that i
thought was very interesting when
during during uh one of the uh pieces
written in the immediate aftermath and
that was
he said the community that sustained the
phoenix has passed from the scene at one
time the boston area was awash in
concert venues record stores guitar
emporiums independent bookstores head
shops the kind of businesses that reach
their customers by advertising and
alternative weeklies
and the reason i thought that was
interesting was because
uh you know you look at harvard square
and what has happened there over the
last 20 years and how that is now a
magnet for tourists in a way that it
wasn't and so on the one hand you could
say well this downtown cambridge
attitude has sort of taken over on the
other hand the tasty's gone the worst
house is gone um
you have a bunch of banks and chain
stores in their place so
are we seeing
with
the passing of the phoenix the sort of
culmination of what has been
this now ongoing trend of the kind of
edges being shown off of what we thought
of as an alternative culture
and and kind of repackaged for four
malls and and mainstream america
in 30 seconds or less i mean it kind of
kind of i mean twas ever thus though
right i mean you know you you know
something becomes popular in the
underground and people in the overground
realize it can sell and then they start
selling it i mean
uh
whatever i just distrust nostalgia and
this is getting into nostalgia for me
and you know
the good old days of the head shops and
um well i i just think i i just i just
think what
whatever will come next is whatever the
alternative to the present is yeah which
is what the whole you know it may well
you know i i have no idea what that will
be
i was a constant enemy
phoenix i mean the part of the part of
the the ever-presentness of the phoenix
was its constant reinvention of itself
over and over and over again the name
was sort of good about that you're
asking about whether or not there was a
sustainable thing there i actually
disagreed with dan a bit about about
what he wrote um in in a way in a broad
sense he's not wrong i mean you're
you're those are accurate changes but um
i also sort of was trying to point out
that there that a lot of the
you know a lot of the things that people
i sort of identified with the older
phoenix you know those things evolved as
well i mean there were you know there
were things in boston that are much more
profitable than sort of some of the
underground things where if you look at
a business like karmaloop like you know
this is a streetwear company that is now
worth you know millions of millions of
dollars um you know it's sort of taken
over for like maybe what newberry comics
was in the 90s or you know what sort of
your head shop was in the 70s i'm not
sure that there i think you know there's
you can sort of go a little bit too far
and say that the audience for that um
evaporated i i certainly felt um a
renewal
especially in the last five years of the
of the newspaper um that i think had
been sort of absent for maybe more than
a decade um with you know
sort of a re-flowering of certainly like
you know diy and punk culture in boston
and um and sort of and surprisingly like
a real strong
base of activism that sort of had been
absent for a lot of my tenure there i
i'm not saying that um uh you know head
shops and and guitar stores were good or
bad um i was just
making a comment about that generally
and i do think that
one thing that um that the phoenix was
able to
seize on as its own
was a sort of part of
boston and a part of life that you
wouldn't see in the globe because it
made people uncomfortable
and there just is it seems to me
that in the same way that um boston is a
safer city than it has ever been um uh
you know i remember being shocked when i
was our a school field trip drove
through the combat zone um you don't
have there aren't really any areas in
the city in what today in which you
would feel like you had to cover up your
kids eyes when you were driving through
that i have kids so i'm happy about that
i'm not i'm not saying that we should
return to that i'll throw that comment
to chris farrell is chris around here
he was he's nodded off um
uh i i i don't know i don't know if
that's necessary i mean yeah it's a
safer city but i i don't know that
there's
that that means that there's nothing
is this like a jane's addiction thing is
there's nothing shocking i i don't i
don't know that that's necessarily the
case i think there are still stories
that
that you can tell that that
differentiate yourself well so you you
know anita your story about that um uh
the andrea dworkin uh um
uh alan dershowitz debate and the way
that you talked about what was actually
going on there instead of talked about
it euphemistically or charlie um uh your
fantastic quote was it daryl dawkins
yeah that you cited um uh when
when the 76ers beat the celtics and a
chant of beat la went up in the boston
garden and the globe sports reporter
asked darryl dawkins what that was like
and he said um when i heard that my dick
got stiff
and uh he he he turned to the phoenix
reporter and said brian we gave it to
michael gates you run
and it was michael's lead
uh um but but in terms of so so you know
still
you're not gonna see cursing in the
pages of the globe but in terms of
subject matter
are there things today that and maybe
carly this is this can be the final
question of this part for for for you or
charlie you can also jump in but are
there things today that the phoenix was
covering that no one else would cover
chris farrow on unoccupied
nobody covered occupy the way he did
nobody in america covered the occupy
movement the way that guy did that i
mean you find your alternative i mean
the thing the thing about this this
business is there will always be a
mainstream therefore there will always
be an alternative but we just have to go
find it was that a failure of the fact
that no one else covered it like chris
did and i agree with that is that
because if chris had been working for um
a quote mainstream publication they
wouldn't have run it because they
weren't interested or just because they
didn't have chris they would have they
wouldn't have run it because it wasn't
within their comprehension to cover it
that way yeah i mean there was and and
just to shout out the other people who
covered that for us ariel shearer and
liz pelley and um we had a couple of
people
doing that they're literally around the
clock um frozen's coverage is amazing of
that um but you remember there was there
were other reporters there there were
globe reporters there they just didn't i
mean it's not like they didn't know
about it um they and not only that i
mean stephen here was covering it from
for the metro um and actually probably
doing the best mainstream job of any of
the mainstream papers just kidding you
who's interested in there um
i'll throw another one out there which
was you know that in the very final days
of the phoenix um when stevenson's
climate coverage which is a very
mainstream issue but the way that he was
covering that i think was pretty
distinctive and had
kind of a a different kind of impact
where he's talking about um you know
essentially a mainstream climate you
know environmentalist movement that is
moving off into um into a mode of
radical action right um and i that he
came to us you know you're talking about
a guy who'd written for the atlantic who
had written for globe idea section who
had been at gbh and wbr and um and could
not get anybody else to publish that
stuff so yeah there's still stuff i was
go ahead chris
this is chris just step up to the mic um
just so because this is recorded and
then we'll have you for posterity
it's not just chris just identify
yourself uh chris farron so i came on
staff in uh uh exactly five years
september 2008.
um but it wasn't just covering the same
stuff other people are covering in a
different way but there's there's just
some there's a i think your your
question is there's still a million
stories in boston i still have a book
full of that i didn't get to write
for the phoenix and trying to do some
you know all over the place there's
still cults
literally on college campuses you know
uh larouche houses
so if you brought that story if you
brought a story of a cult on a college
campus to boston magazine
um or uh or to the globe uh you know to
the ideas section or would do you think
they would say
we're not interested in that i don't
really i don't mess with the globe but
otherwise it's like uh
um
only because uh they know who i am at
this point but if you know if your young
writer out there is going to come out
and you have like a badass story i mean
it probably will get stolen um
so you're just better off doing it for
an independent outlet i mean i guess my
point was it's not that they wouldn't
run it they wouldn't and if you know
they'd water it down or whatever as far
as i mean the way that we got to do
stuff at the phoenix is really not
another outlet where you can get paid
the i mean i traveled i was on the road
for four months a year like is just like
he's an all-weekly reporter that's what
that's what they look like and they
don't
there's there's still a lot of stories
they don't get to write for others the
look stays by the way in case you didn't
notice that
the salaries go up a little bit but the
look stays
he's a maniac i mean like there's he's
just
like the way that he reports stories the
way that i agree no we need to start
talking with the fact that paper and is
is um i have a 27 year old daughter who
does not pick this up right and she
reads the new york times that's because
it's not in existence uh she doesn't
she reads the new york times she does
not read the paper i don't read the new
york times
and so i think that's i mean there's
room the question is how do we create a
phoenix-like world with editors who can
help people and where readers can find
this stuff on the internet and that's
where it has to go yeah there's a little
bit of stirring like that and oddly
enough in my other
life as a sports writer there's a couple
of sites
that are doing long-form sports
reporting with a fully edited glenn
stout who many of you may know from uh
he runs the best american sports writing
he has a
i think it's
called word plow or something which is a
long form journalism site
uh espn.com is doing a lot of long form
uh what i do basically is i print the
stories out and then read them in
hardcop because i'm an old guy but
so there i mean at least in those pla
and somebody's doing a long-form
political site now and i can't remember
who it is i just i read about it the
other day uh nationally can i make one
i'll make one other comment about the
phoenix service as a boston institution
as a you know removed from all the old
weekly stuff um
you know that this is something that
this it was a thing that you picked up
on the week on thursdays or you know in
the old days on fridays and it was like
the bible of what was going on in boston
and and it had everything in it and uh
yes it's been disaggregated by the
internet but there isn't anything that
anybody started in boston of any of the
websites that you pick up and you can
find out what bands are playing and what
bands are good and what theater's
playing and what you should be thinking
about and what books to read and that
that i mean obviously that this is not
like this is not rocket science but when
the thing goes away you start to miss it
um and i was sort of shocked that even
you know i would sort of like it's like
having a phantom limb you're like you
should you're looking for this thing
that you're like wait i know where to
find that but it's not i i was right
after the marathon bombings
i actually
i knew the phoenix didn't exist
but the thought that came into my mind
is
it's thursday i have to go pick up the
phoenix because i really want to read
something meaningful about
that event which everyone was covering
right
you know
to argue with anita a little bit about
nostalgia
there
you know there was a period
in boston theater in the late 60s and
early 70s
where you could go to the loeb drama
center and see tommy lee jones as cory
elena's and stockard channing as
isabella in measure for measure or jenny
in
three penny opera
john lithgow was
acting in and directing plays this was a
period of about
seven years
there's been nothing
nothing in boston
like that since then
there was sarah caldwell
doing amazing productions of operas that
the met
hadn't quite heard of yet though they
figured it out later we were getting
amazing
productions of
you know of
that was that were revelations
um
robert lowell was in boston teaching at
harvard
and
there's nothing like that and these and
the phoenix
is sort of in
phoenix had a really great run
and it's
horrible that it doesn't exist anymore
it's so sad that it doesn't exist
anymore but it's one of those things
that
is really irreplaceable
and i and i think you know
we could talk about the art and what
they're doing um which i think is pretty
impressive these days but uh i do want
to i do want to move on um and make sure
we get to the audience part of this we
have thumbs down for the art yeah
okay
let's argue about theater
so um yeah so let's move on oh one thing
i did just wanna and when we were
talking about some of the phoenix's
coverage uh i just wanted to to point
out um one incredibly impressive piece
of reporting the fact that it's 10 years
ago does not at all mean that this
stopped over the last 10 years but um
one of the things the globe gets credit
for a huge amount of credit for is its
coverage of um of the catholic church uh
in in in the early part of the last
decade um and this was a story that
phoenix was writing about for months
before the globe picked it up um uh so
it
here was a story i don't know if the
globe would or would not have come upon
it
um but it certainly was a story that
that uh that the phoenix was at first
it's about harvey's not here i should
have oh reach out to him anyway yes
please and please identify yourself sure
i'm mark tamizawa and
i grew up in chicago says the chicago
reader which is still going
um and wfmt which was an all classical
station with people
um who spoke their minds rather well
um
i i wanted to add i didn't want this to
feel like a funeral
um yes
okay yeah right that's tomorrow at seven
o'clock seven o'clock seven o'clock
because here's what i'm going to say the
old english expression i think is the
difference between a grave and a rut is
dimension
you've talked about lots of structural
things i think it's not nostalgic to say
what part of the structure is universal
and goes way back to the best of
narrative
and how does that structure come to life
come to life on the internet
and i'd like to suggest that with a
certain man buying the globe and with
the amazing talent we have in boston
including the dean of bu's
communications department who made
the herald digital
that we have the people all right i i
saw the little grimace see we may have a
difference of opinion about what
happened
but i'm just saying that boston
has this urge to become great again
right technically we lost it to silicon
valley we've given it away twice wait
let's make i just want to make sure that
there's a question because they have a
lot of very opinionated people in the
audience oh there is but this is all
structure and this is opportunity okay
this is not pathological
so the idea is this we go to john henry
and say you need to create a new version
of whatever it is you need an alt
version of the globe and you've got the
people who can do it okay but what is
the question
no i'm i'm trying to i'm trying
that's essentially what boston.com hired
me to do when i got
one right after the phoenix time um and
um and they'll be launching
a site that is something like that
probably mid october and does it last
question does it include really talented
people like him and the younger versions
of him get damn well better
but there's no guarantee that it will no
i mean and and but they're i mean
they're in there they'll invite it
and there's no guarantees that even if
it does it'll succeed yeah but um but
yeah i mean the the question is is there
an opportunity and yeah there's an
enormous opportunity there's an
opportunity for the dig there's a
there's another all weekly in town and
and there's an opportunity for um boston
magazine
uh maybe yeah so i just hope that mit
will be a big player in that because mit
has i can almost guarantee that mit will
not be a big player in starting although
oddly enough i mean no no no no you say
that but but it's setting the structure
up i was gonna say okay in um isn't that
what joey ito is talking about now is
spreading out the media lab to the rest
of the world so isn't all a way of
innovating i'm just trying to get yeah
yeah okay um we do i mean
um
in trying to think about like whether
there would be a place online for for
some new kind of thing with a lot of the
same kinds of people who are who are
doing stuff to phoenix um
uh we did talk to we talked to the mit
game lab actually um and he was involved
in this and i hope they i mean i'm not
i'm distanced from that from that
process at this point obviously but um
but it's ongoing and i think i think
there's an opportunity for anybody who
wants to who really cares about that
stuff um you also i think
all of us on this stage and a lot of
people who are here have
a sense just an innate sense of what an
enormous job that is to do on a
week-to-week basis it's easy to do for a
little while
but it's hard to do for 40 years i think
that's one of the lessons of the dig um
and uh i know everybody has differing
opinions on on stephen mindich who kept
us in the game for 46 years but he made
extraordinary contributions um of money
and of time and of um
and lots of other stuff um over the
years and and
yeah john henry's definitely you know
one of those sort of rich people who can
subsidize the thing but um those people
are pretty are pretty rare now
my my point about that guaranteeing the
mit was not going to do that i didn't
mean mit was not going to
help create new structures mit is not
going to go and work with the globe on
bringing a phoenix-like
outlet to boston.com or the globe why i
don't i don't think it doesn't matter
because i'm not in a position to make
that and you can ask joey if you want to
okay i will all right thanks yes
um a couple of uh thoughts for your
consideration
questions make sure it's a question yeah
they're questions um
the
when you you you touched on what i think
is most important the the phoenix
started as boston after dark it started
as what you described a kind of calendar
listing
um and so seems to me that was always
the core at least what what i liked
about the phoenix
uh when it the phoenix bought you know
that whole complicated history um so
i guess number one isn't there a place
and i think you've touched on it a
little for a hard copy version of
something you pick up on a weekly basis
that has all the music and the lectures
and everything else what i found useful
about the phoenix secondly the phoenix
went from being let's let's make sure
there's a question yeah
don't worry just well you're already on
number two yeah okay well if you listen
i think you'll hear it
um
i think the first one was now here's the
second um
the phoenix
went down a road that i completely
horrified me um and i think it was sort
of self-destruction when it switched
over from the paper version into this
glossy thing with this whole new
advertising strategy
which turned it into the yuppie
extraordinaire publication which i had
no interest in whatsoever maybe there's
a new market out there that but
evidently didn't respond
no one i don't think has talked yet
about that particular thing that
happened which led directly to the
demise of that version of the
publication and the link to that
question is
i just came back from maine a short
while ago and there's a portland version
of the phoenix that's still going yeah
it's right here and there's a and
there's a provenance version if i'm not
mistaken so why is it i don't you know
no one has really explained how it's
possible to have a phoenix in portland
unless i missed it at the very beginning
of this carly you might i know you might
have something to say about this but i
think that's something that you see
actually around the country
in that smaller communities are having a
much easier time sustaining all weeklies
than large cities because uh
what what all weeklies are giving um
truly cannot be found in those cities
you see it um throughout the south you
see it in portland where's you see it in
providence i guess i
what you're talking about is i think
pretty pretty accurate and this is one
of the things um that i
i've mentioned a few times in different
contexts but um i was on the the board
of directors for the the alternative
weekly
group which is all like there's like 150
of them in the country and it is one of
the things that one of the trends you
see is it's a big city ones um you know
the village voices of iraq right now um
the phoenix obviously is dead um but in
the small medium markets a lot of those
papers are becoming almost papers of
record and the the couple that i tend to
mention one is um seven days in vermont
which is a fantastic paper and growing
and doing great stuff um and um
what's the one in in jackson mississippi
i'm gonna miss i'm gonna forget that but
there's a there's also there's a couple
of really good ones um and and so yeah i
mean the
you know i definitely i mean i heard
believe me you're not the first person
to say that that they hated the glossy
version um we disagree i mean i thought
it was a great a great magazine and um
and um you know they're one of the
things that i think i i
personally underestimated uh when we
went to the glossy was that the phoenix
represented not just
um
what was there because we we went
through a great effort to keep long-form
journalism in it to keep all the to
actually add to our arts coverage um and
to and to make a space for all the
things that made the phoenix the phoenix
um but it made a perfect sense to me
after afterwards that people responded
to to the phoenix as being some what was
not there i mean the part of what what
it meant to be this newspaper version of
the phoenix was that it wasn't on glossy
paper and that and it didn't have these
gorgeous pretty pictures um and there's
a there was a grittiness to it that this
certainly was lost although um
i can tell you that inside that
newspaper there are a lot of us who are
really excited to have the opportunity
to do the magazine version i also miss
cyprus
david i i wonder if i could ask the
panel to please please identify yourself
i'm sorry i'm david thorburn the
director of the communications forum
this is very rich interesting discussion
but i i'm listening to it partly as an
as an outsider and i think that one
problem with the discourse so far has
been that the people who are uh
phoenix writers and phoenix uh long-time
phoenix readers certainly know what
everyone is alluding to but for those of
us who have a less full sense of what
the issues are it isn't entirely clear
what's so alternative about what you've
described one here's one thing i got i'm
sure is right that there was a much
greater and more systematic and
respectful emphasis on what we'll call
popular culture and that
the phoenix like other alternative
weeklies or non mainstream publications
helped to naturalize the notion now very
widespread that these distinctions are
unhelpful uh that seems so one thing is
clear to me that one thing that
distinguished the uh phoenix in its in
its heyday at least was this kind of
emphasis uh but but uh what in other and
then another thing that you uh you're
telling us distinguished it was the
quality of its contributors and its
writing which of course i accept and
understand in fact my experience with
the phoenix certainly confirms that
tremendously so uh um
but still
what else about the phoenix made it so
alternative what really distinguished it
from uh the globe or from other things
and and have we really are there no
other spaces online where such things
are available
two things i can think of right off the
bat first of all george campbell
nobody wrote about sports the way george
kimball did anywhere in america i mean
if if anybody i during my time at the
phoenix can be said to have reinvented a
form of journalism it was george kimble
uh simply by
leaving the press box
uh i would think i think you could say
the same thing about dave o'brien at
that point nobody was covering the media
in boston as a beat people have done
media criticism before going back to
you know liebling and menken and
everyone else nobody else was doing that
uh at the time um
those those those are two that those are
just so part of the part of the point
charlie is the is the uh the uh
um
boldness and and and uh uh
non-mainstream interests of the of the
of the of the writers it was also no
it's also non-mainstream style it was
also non-mainstream
vocabulary it was also i mean everything
about the two that i mentioned and i
hope most of the work the rest of us did
was everything about it was alternative
except for the basic journalism as anita
said which was always solid but the
approaches to stories the discoveries i
remember to this day
in 1980 right before i left 8283 we had
a terrific writer named neil miller and
he kept coming to me or coming to
meetings with this story about this
weird disease that gay men were getting
and were dying of
and even at the phoenix people weren't
didn't see the story i mean it was just
this kind of strange thing
but but neil dogged it and i mean i mean
and i mean i don't know that the globe
has had the globe had anybody on it then
but it wasn't it wasn't just it wasn't
just the the the
the approach that was alternative it was
it was the way we did we all did our
jobs know in a fashion that was the
alternative to what was then the
mainstream would you i can't i can't
explain it to you without taking you
back to what the globe was exactly and
what the globe still is i think you know
charlie's got a a real a great
perspective on this having been
at a bunch of these places for
significantly longer than the rest of us
have but um even to get a peek inside
what a daily newspaper is like and the
strictures that are put on that in many
ways there there i mean there are lots
of great things that the globe is able
to do but there's just there there are
patently things that they cannot do and
don't wish to do that you know that left
open a a vast spectrum of so part of it
are then is are are the oppressive
standards of of convention and taste
that keep the mainstream media from
looking at certain kinds of questions
entirely i mean wait a minute because i
did get to write so did you at the
magazine at the globe when they when
we're given the opportunity to stretch
out and at boston magazine when i worked
for dave o'brien i and i wrote about the
aids epidemic and early on and um and
was given a lot of time as well as space
to fill those things out so
it's it's not just the outlets it's also
the fact that all of our print
everything is shrinking so much you
can't do that anymore in the globe
magazine there's just no space and
there's no time there's no money to pay
the reporters so that's it so it's not
just the media outlet it's it's what's
happened to journalism and to our and to
paper in the last yes in other words
what you're doing you're linking the
demise of the of the phoenix in part to
the yeah tremendous transformations that
were really certainly making all right
yes
i mean please make sure you identify
yeah sure hi i'm reika murthy um i'm
actually a cms alum from far too long
ago now hi david um so i heard chris
talk about all the stories that he still
has left to be told and i heard anita
talk about how do you create a phoenix
online
and i'm in the public radio space where
um local more and more gets talked about
as a differentiator for stations that
otherwise can be bypassed by all sorts
of other channels besides broadcast for
the same national programs
however i feel like local
media doesn't get respect when it comes
down to it and and i'm not just saying
that in public radio i think in general
and what i'd love to hear from all of
you is when you say respect do you mean
within the industry or from an audience
both i think okay i mean obviously this
is all anecdotal um but that's why i
want to hear from you guys what i want
to hear is
when you were at the phoenix what were
your perceptions i mean it's all
anecdotal it's very qualitative i mean
you can bring circulation in if that's
useful but i want to get a sense not of
how advertisers felt about
advertising in the phoenix but i want to
get a sense from you guys of how you
felt the community and appetite among
the readers and among the boston scene
the movers and shakers as well as the
alts
what was the appetite for local media
for talking about it for reading about
it for even knowing that there were
local stories i mean that's another
issue
and how do you see that i want to talk
about that but can you also bring in the
internet too because there's such a
perception now that there's so much
media and there's too much of it but
obviously there's so many stories that
aren't getting told so just over time
i'd love to hear what you think i'm
really big on local media and local
radio i'm and everybody i know talks
about it all the time um and the local
outlets um lloyd and i were talking
about the very long report we heard in
the car today about the opera that's
this new opportunity there's no opera
thing that's i would never in a million
years know about that nor would i
necessarily read about it i'm not sure
that i would do that on bur on bur um
and the kind of the kind of arts
reporting they're doing there the kind
of local reporting they're doing and
also on gbh although anyway um
i really think the bur report the
reporting is really it's it's quite
interesting and some of the other you
know i'm also a new big fan of tell me
more which is a national uh show i'm so
glad you just said that because i walk
around saying how great and underplayed
it is yes and this is um this is a show
about minority voices and
brilliant uh hostess and uh and i said
that because you should know it's a
woman and um and this great barbershop
thing on fridays it's just it's terrific
so i'm actually very excited about local
radio and in terms of the audience it's
all anecdotal it's all you know how many
letters did you get how many emails did
you get what's the response but it's
just in terms of the chatter i actually
think that that local radio is where
it's happening what about local news
what about a culture around local news
and people's expectations for reading it
prioritizing it are they going to read
the globe or are they going to read the
next national political website i think
that's what i not just said i'm still
hungry for the for the globe website or
not the globe somebody to do a local
website and i don't and the thursday
afternoon thing doesn't do it for me
because if it's tuesday i want to know
it's uh you know things change so i want
i want a website that does boston after
dark and i want it to be really good and
i wanted to have reviews on it and it
you know and so it needs somebody needs
to aggregate that for the city of boston
for the for the greater boston area my
follow-up would be you guys did it in
print
obviously you did it in
various different contexts
how might one do it in the future
because you guys are among the few who
succeeded do it online it's got to be
done online it's got to be done but
i don't know what are the elements
i think just like by constraints of time
we're not going to have any business
plans somebody in this room knows how
somebody in this room knows how to do
that
i do have one follow-up and i'm talking
about tell me more and uh focus on
minority voices um that's something that
historically the phoenix
uh had a varied record on in in terms of
representing
um uh
do any of you have any thoughts about
why that is and what that
says about an alternative weekly and
about the alternative weekly culture um
that there was that varied record white
it's white yeah it's white what what is
it the the the culture of the phoenix
that i knew was white it was white that
was it
there was there was whatever attempts
were made so you had you had this there
was nobody of color in there i'm sorry
david i'm sure somewhere in the history
of the phoenix there was a person of
color but
in my four fives charlie no
you had you had a community of people
who had um uh a counterculture
perspective who were
pushing back against middle class
against i mean we we covered a lot of
stories
out of the
different communities in boston but we
did so as as yeah and he said a pretty
white paper
but we did i mean there's certainly dave
o'brien's work on the james bowden case
uh which i don't know if anybody
remembers now but we i mean we were we
were out there covering stories as we
were everywhere that other people
weren't getting to it's just that the
composition of the staff was the way it
was and that's why and one of the i
wrote it i wrote a blog about the voices
on on npr and the names on npr just
saying magna chakrabarty makes me feel
good um and all of those names um all of
the names of uh who i can't identify
necessarily where they came from i think
that's that's a tremendous shift in in
what we're hearing um on the air and i
think that's really exciting so i i'm
really looking forward to what happens
with um with radio and i'm hope and i'm
hoping it will stay local to that to
that extent too it's exciting but just
bring it back to the phoenix why you
know we have people here who
collectively were at the paper for
decades and decades um
was that a discussion that you had and
if not why not
i think it's all the time yeah it was a
oh my god
that's why i asked the question
that's why i asked the question i i
think it was it was constant not just
for not just for the phoenix but for all
weeklies in general um
the the jackson free press which is the
one i was trying to think of in in
jackson mississippi is the only alt
weekly i know it was just it started
online and then became a print paper um
that has um a racially diverse
um
staff staff and and as well as the
readership um
you know i
but i think i think the other thing to
remember is that that at the time
there were and this is certainly no
excuse but at the time there was a
thriving
black press news press
around the country i mean there was a
lot of the good talent went to the
institute went to the amsterdam news in
new york or or the banner here or or the
chicago defender and there was a race
that was still a lot that was still uh
that was still a lot it was that was
still alive
radio stations i'm sure local
i mean there was a universe of
african-american media that was still
thriving at that point uh which i which
is no excuse which is no excuse for the
you know for the way we were but that
that's the fact
yes
hi i'm caroline o'donovan from the
neiman journalism lab um and i'm sorry
to go back to all of these things but i
did kind of want to talk about a paid
model for
for long form and for magazine writing
and for narrative and i mean we've
introduced some of those examples
grantland some other things um and maybe
there is no answer maybe the answer is
not in this room right now but we've
talked about the web a little bit and in
terms of unbundling that so i'm not
talking about local i'm not talking
about listings not even necessarily
talking about boston but if we're
talking about making the kind of the
really the meat of the writing that you
guys did profitable
um
and obviously you said you're still
doing it charlie you said you're still
doing it and getting paid for it
presumably um where and how is that
happening and how can we make well i'm
not i'm not doing long form online i'm
doing a blog for esquire and a 1500 word
column for grantland that's not what i
don't consider that long form uh the
stuff i do for the the for esquire
magazine is what i consider long form
and i'm still doing that for print
i just mentioned that i know a couple of
people i can't remember who's doing
somebody is launching a political
website
of with long-form political journalism
and i heard about it while i was in
washington the last couple days and i
can't remember somebody fairly
famous but i mean and i can't remember
who it is but anyway in any event glenn
stout is doing it in sports writing
right now part of the genius of the alt
weeklies was i mean and you hear this
constantly across all kinds of
journalism that the the long-form stuff
has traditionally not been thought of as
stuff that pays the bills
so this was sort of you know the idea of
it being that bible the street bible the
thing that people would pick up um
the business model for all weeklies was
you had this audience of
you know 18 to 36 year olds who like had
disposable time and disposable income
and just really wanted to go out and be
involved in the cultural life of the
city
and if you could
have this thing that everybody wanted to
pick up and read
because of all the you know essentially
this great you know rock writing and
this great like you know but they've
read the ads the same way that they read
the the copy um that you could afford to
have to build all the space that made
room for all the stuff that we we love
to do what do we get paid
live on believe it or not in jamaica
plain
five years but yeah not today is one of
the reasons that there was so much
turnover at the field right exactly
because
because there was a kind of ceiling we
were fairly easily outbid is what lloyd
yes
right i don't know what you were playing
harvey harvey silvergate um actually
wrote about this and how he went to uh
steve mindich the publisher at one point
and said look you know we could build
this stable of all-time great writers if
we just paid them more and steve
according to harvey flipped his lid and
you know essentially said i'm not going
to tell you how to practice the law you
don't tell me how to publish my paper
but
i guess harvey's impression was that one
of the
one of the things that stephen
eventually said to him in conversation
one of the lessons there was that there
if you pay people a comfortable wage
then you don't get that constant
infusion of new talent um
it was a pain in the neck but it was
sort of understood could be a
publisher's way of justifying paying
people a non-livable wage however it is
worth pointing out that you know
you were there for five years
it was graduate school yeah it was
graduate school it was not a plan but so
i i think it does speak to this just a
second because of about monetizing it so
we we were given a chance and the
opportunity and in exchange in exchange
for not getting paid a lot we were we
were given great editors and we you know
we we understood that there was an
exchange there um i don't know how that
works um online and i don't know if it
still works but well ariana i think is
discovered enough to pay anybody
anything at all so
how it could work online so um so i mean
that you know again i the nostalgia here
has to be tempered with what we were
getting paid and what we weren't getting
paid and why people had to leave because
they didn't
some people had to have had real jobs
and then they wrote for the phoenix
right like me like yeah yeah
they're they're um i mean there are this
isn't the topic of this forum but there
are places like the atavist and byliner
that are only publishing long form you
know five to fifteen thousand word
pieces and uh have an economic model um
that involves paying for those pieces
who knows if that will work but
certainly that's right there's also a
journalist in the back of the room r
johnson who's do sort of pioneering the
model of just sort of having your own
like online magazine like that is on
your ipod and like you know it's in the
itunes store and like then you assign
your friends stories and you know and
people pay you for a subscription to
that sure and i can't remember the name
of the it might be what you're talking
about but someone is doing an ebook
single thing right now out of esquire
it's esquire editors
i think they're using the kindle they're
using like a candlestick kind of thing
let's go ahead yeah i can yes my name is
david rosenbaum uh the question was
raised what what made the phoenix old
uh i walked into the phoenix in 1973
23 years old
and
they said okay write something and we'll
pay you
i couldn't have walked into the new york
times i couldn't have walked into the
village voice village voice was too
scary
been around for a long time couldn't
walk into the herald but i could walk
into the phoenix and they may not have
paid a lot
i think they paid me 75 dollars
but 75 is more than i remember get paid
online i remember getting i remember
getting 35 actually well a few years
later so i think it was hot at the
end we were paying what 35 bucks for a
record review well this was a this was
150 for half paper book review 30. we
cut it instead of dollars we don't need
to revisit oh but the point
i don't know where i have a
friend's son who is now an editor at
slate
and basically what he does is edit stuff
that people write for free and put it up
and because it's the web and it's in
you got to fill
in an infinite amount of space you talk
about long-form fulfill an infinite
amount of space
constantly i don't you can't pay these
people
so
the validation i got from that 75 bucks
i'm sorry anita
allowed me to say okay i can maybe do
this this might be a profession for me i
don't know where that exists but that
at that time was what made it
alternative is that it was a place for
not a journalism person
you know just somebody off the street
with a college education to say when i
try writing
and then i got support for it
we're going to move into um a lightning
round where you all need to answer as
many questions as possible in 60 seconds
or less uh
i guess they're not a lot of wait wait
don't tell me listeners in the audience
um but uh we do only have um 15 minutes
left so we are going to try and keep
questions and answers even more succinct
than usual so we can get to everyone um
and a reminder that there will be a
reception afterwards so we can continue
uh this kind of yes i'll make you know
i'll remind everyone right before we go
and where it is but we can continue this
discussion uh there as well yes hi uh
kelly kreitz with cms uh i want to pick
on on something that came up in david's
question but also has been a little bit
of an underlying theme in what a lot of
you have said which is um this idea of
your writing having been a craft that
word came up a lot and and the idea that
what was really alternative about the
phoenix was the quality of the writing
or the art
or the craft to use your word um which
is a
really different kind of conversation
about what might be quote lost
if as journalism changes than i've heard
in um other communications forums for
example when we're maybe talking with
journalists who represent mainstream
outlets um and one thing that makes me
think is that um you know for thinking
about the the craft of the writing as
part of what made what you were doing
alternative and part of what you want to
try to
you know see what that future might be
in digital media um
it puts the phoenix into a kind of
history that i mean there's a history of
alternative spaces in print that goes
beyond journalism so it makes me you've
talked about new journalism which sort
of walked the line between literature
and journalism in the 1970s but also
literary magazines in the late 19th
century and early 20th century and it
makes me think that you know you could
argue well there's a history that has to
do with changes in media technologies of
a sort of shifting line between the way
we think about the literary and the
journalistic um and so maybe there's
there's a there's a future for something
like the phoenix that isn't within the
realm of professional journalism maybe
it is you know some new way of thinking
about the literary or another kind of
art
space so i'm just i think i'm asking
maybe for you to talk a little bit more
about this artistic side of of of what
the phoenix represented and and is there
another place to look for where it could
you want to first yeah let me let me
just
give you a a a little anecdote
um
this is about uh pulitzer prizes
uh
i think lloyd is the only one on the
panel can speak with an expertise here
i'm just telling you i was gonna say
between the five of us
but
i i served i served on the pulitzer jury
for a couple of years after i won my
award
uh and i had um a very interesting
conversation with my fellow
jurors
as far as i know
and i may be getting the numbers wrong
only
three or four
writers in my category
have ever won a pulitzer prize in the
history of the category of criticism and
what do you mean in your category
criticism category is criticism
the pulitzer prize in criticism no no no
no actually i'm no no i'm i'm gonna
make that more general three or four
only three or four pulitzer prize
winners have ever won for working on an
alternative weekly for working on a
weekly
when i was a
juror
i was
blown away
by an art critic uh
for the la weekly
who seemed to me to be transforming
the nature of art criticism and who is
an absolutely brilliant writer
and in the discussion
that
you know we went through to choose the
three
finalists
i said something like
this guy is the best writer of the 1100
you know contr you know contenders that
we saw
and
one of my uh colleagues on the jury who
was a managing editor of a major daily
newspaper
said you can say who it is i know i'm
not going to say who it is
not from here not from boston
doesn't matter
uh said i'm not interested in good
writing i'm interested in someone who
can fill that space every day
and i was totally outvoted
the person that i
thought was
you know should have won the prize and
certainly should have been a finalist
wasn't even considered it was totally
outvoted by the other jurors but that
sounds like a philosophical
question about whether a pulitzer prize
winner for criticism should be someone
who has to file every day or whether
if you write three columns and and
they're the best columns you can submit
those but in terms of your question
about craft right and and
yeah i wanted i wanted
the difference to answer your question
the difference
at the phoenix for me was editors
there's one thing that drives me
freaking crazy about daily newspapers
absolutely out of my mind
is
a newspaper a newspaper a newspaper will
promote a writer to be an editor
that's like promoting a gardener to be a
plumber
i know it i know brilliant editors i've
had brilliant editors i married a
brilliant editor
i can't edit copy
everything i edit comes out sounding
like me and we know how my writers just
love that uh it's a different skill set
it's a different it's a different
calling it's a different craft to use
the word
and i think that the first place i
learned that was at the phoenix was that
there were people who
you know
frankly i wrote better than they did but
boy they edited much better i mean it
was just
when you gave them your thing it came
back to you in your voice
looking better than it did
the ability to do that to work the craft
of editing within the writer's voice
without losing the writer's voice i mean
that that to me is as distant from my
ability as flying the space shuttle i
don't know how anyone does it though
some of those editors were terrific
writers i was about to say i was going
to say i was thinking of cliff
yeah who was an amazing writer as well
as a great area but i think that's about
in terms of the craft that's what that's
what differentiated the phoenix for me
as a place where you know i wasn't
completely starting out there but it was
really the first place i really i always
felt like i spread my wings it was
because i i developed an appreciation
and a through demonstration of the craft
of editing
yeah
um
three blindingly fast comments and then
just identify yourself first scott
muncie
and uh three blendingly fast comments
and then one extraordinarily succinct
question um first of all in terms of the
economics of way back then i love to
torment 20 somethings about with my 350
a month two-bedroom apartment in
cambridgeport rent control it was vastly
cheaper and easier
to live and to be independent and to do
noticeably back then yes
two uh glove versus the phoenix what is
alternative
um one of the most important aspects of
that is where is the money coming from i
mean you know the globe had filings and
you know major national accounts and all
sorts of stuff you know where did the
money come from for the phoenix that
certainly wasn't all of it but it had a
major impact on
the difference between the two
publications um the only reason number
three i visit esquire magazine online
every single damn day
is charlie pierce oh and there
that should be an example and there
should be money in that
for the people that can do that for
publications so you know they should i
mean the writers and also uh the online
publication should be looking into
monetizing good journalism in that
fashion so here's the extraordinarily
succinct question earlier anita was
talking about
curation websites
that bring together good folks and then
charlie immediately started talking
about
um
you know how you guys had great editors
back in the day
and i was wondering do you guys have any
examples of any current websites that
provide good editorial nurturing
for uh journalistic writers online now
there must be some i think josh marshall
does a great job at talking points memo
he's been doing it for a while
i think politico could be but it's not i
think politico is one thing about
politico
is a tremendous it is a tremendous lost
opportunity because it could be exactly
what you're talking about and it's not
um
i will leave the floor open for any
other reason
there's
the
seems to me the best of the
online
boston
arts reviews is the arts fuse
which is bill marx's
website
and i think there is
there's there seems to be very good
editing there are some very good writers
that would be more good writers if
anyone was getting paid
and and the the the those long form the
long form only outlets uh have some
excellent excellent editors there some
refugees from wired and the new yorker
uh and they put an enormous i haven't
written for them but know a lot of
people who have and they put an enormous
amount of effort um into editing those
10 and 15 000 word pieces
so maybe the senses
the one other thing too which is that
you know i think if you look at what bur
has done online um
to sort of do some arts stuff over there
um yeah i think there's a there's a
possibility for that to become
you know bigger outlet they've got some
interesting you know their non-profit
they've got some money um they might be
able to afford to pay some people um and
there and there is that sort of
institutional backing for for the arts
there so that that could become you know
a new base for some of that stuff
one point i just want to i want to make
sure we touch on or at least mention
before we go and that's something that
um dan kennedy was talking about here
and that's the effect that the collapse
of the classified uh market had on all
weeklies um and uh you know we can
debate in retrospect the phoenix's move
to go free but when they stopped
charging and then
no longer had the classifieds um yeah
but we survived that i mean not to not
to say that that wasn't a blow but it
was a blow to regular newspapers as well
i don't think that all weeklies were any
more or less
you know and in fact there's a case we
made that we were less affected than
than the dailies were where the dailies
were immediately cutting their circular
not their circulation but there but you
know where you saw 50 cuts in staff at
dailies that was out of the circulation
stuff i'm sorry out of the classified
stuff where the phoenix did lose a lot
of its classifieds but i mean that
wasn't the below that killed us that was
sort of the 2006 where you saw the paper
but it would have been a blow that
killed you if someone hadn't been
subsidizing it
um
i mean steven was losing a fair amount
of money at the end well and and that's
sort of that's the sort of oz behind the
curtain thing so i i don't have it i
don't have i can't tell you for sure
that that's right or wrong um but i can
tell you that um that we weren't having
discussions about the end of the
newspaper in 2006 and we were having
those like three years later um when
we'd sort of stable it seemed to me at
least that we had stabilized after
the classifieds had gone away and you
know sort of restructured around you
know it was then it was the drop
dropping out of national advertising
which is which would seem to me to be
the the more of a body blow than the
classified advertising um i think we
probably have time for one more question
this will be very quick my name is fred
hapgood i have one question why is it
that the
financial model for alternative
newspapers seems more viable in smaller
communities
less competition
yeah there's really nobody else yeah
that was that
that was absolutely yeah that was a very
question and i think the most succinct
answer
what it's smaller no smaller pawn lower
overhead cheeks
i mean i wish we had gotten more people
on the record for this i just there's so
many people i have questions for in this
audience so i hope you're all coming to
this thing afterwards
um
so that's probably as good a place
to wrap it up as any we obviously could
have continued this for many hours
one of the ways we can continue it is by
partaking of
crudites and wine and beer and assorted
soft drinks um i think technically
starting at 7 30 but we can probably
start heading over
that's at the r d pub which is on the
fourth floor of this data center uh the
data center is the um
i guess unique would be a nice way to
phrase it looking frank gary building
that is on vassar street
we will all be walking over there so you
can just sort of follow us um i also
want to
point out the other two forums that we
have scheduled um for this semester both
of which should be really excellent uh
the first is on um october 10th
uh and that is with john paul free um
and ethan zuckerman uh and that's
talking about how the generation born in
the digital age is different from its
analog ancestors um and the second uh is
an entire forum just about long-form
journalism uh what's going on with it
and where it's going um
looking specifically at the atlantic my
colleague tom levinson will be
moderating that and jim fallows uh
national correspondent from the atlantic
will be there as will his editor uh
corby cummer um who in addition to being
an editor is uh is a food writer but
cory
i know from personal experience is is a
really excellent excellent editor that's
on december 5th i'll send you an email
to
yes um so again thank you all for coming
uh i do apologize that we didn't have
time to get to everyone's questions um
uh but i hope as many of you as possible
do join us afterwards and i would really
like to thank the four of you
um who uh uh who put up with me
um for this and uh and and sat here i
know you all had a lot more to say and
we were limited in time so it was
excellent having you all
and let's give them a big round of
applause